(meows)
(screams)
(bouncy piano music)
- Am I looking forward to
tasting some chocolate?
Of course! It's chocolate.
(bouncy piano music)
(upbeat techno music)
- Why is it wrapped like a present?
(meows)
(gasps)
- Oh my God!
(laughs)
- It's a kitten!
- Oh my God, it's kittens!
Oh my God, it's kittens!
(squeals)
- What? This is the best day of my life!
- Oh, this isn't chocolate!
- Oh my God, hello!
- This is so much better than chocolate.
- Oh my God, these are so precious!
- Oh, you're making noises!
- Oh, he's so small!
- I care so little about
chocolate right now.
- They're so fuzzy!
- Where's his tail? Oh, he does have one.
I thought he didn't have a tail.
- You are mine and we are leaving.
(bouncy piano music)
- Cats are the best. (laughs)
If you bite the mic, we
can't use this audio.
- Cats are great because you
work for their attention,
but they also will love
you so unconditionally.
- We hold dogs up as
being man's best friend.
There are a lot of cats that can give you
just as much love and that need homes.
- You just gotta find a cat that's
catered to your personality.
If you want a chill
cat, they're out there.
If you want a little demon like
this guy, they're out there.
- There's so many cats in
shelters that need homes,
so if you can, you should
foster them or adopt them.
- Any time I open a box,
I'm hoping that there are kittens in it
and this time it was true.
- I'll take all of them, don't worry.
I'll have all the cats. (laughs)
Ow!
- I like to wrestle with my cats...
with my hands, you know, not my full body.
I'm not a maniac.
(meows)